dana fox who's the word right now we are
also hearing
that president trump is removing brad
parscale as campaign manager
new york times says he's been demoted
have you confirmed this have you heard
anything about this
we have not heard much from him late
lately
yes i think that this uh the president
has actually put out a statement as well
uh
you know twitter's been messed up but i
think put out a statement on on facebook
i actually have it here that
he's pleased to announce that bill
stephen remember bill stephen was at the
white house
and he was moved over to the campaign
just a couple of months ago he will
become
the trump campaign manager and brad is
going to be
handling all the digital work that he
was known for and famous for in 2016
and he'll remain a senior advisor on the
campaign so i
i think you know brad is to be admired
he has
done a lot to get the campaign to where
it is today um but
i think that the president recognizing
that this election is going to be
different from 2016
had to make this change or wanted to
make this change and you have to admire
brad for being willing to
set pride aside and stick with the team
and work with them to try to
beat vice president biden he's raised a
lot of money
he put the groundwork together put the
team together but maybe the president
wants somebody with more experience to
bring him over the next four months
he's never shy about making a change
with his campaign
or the administration and we know that
brad parscale was was put there by
ivanka trump and jared kushner and they
play major roles with the president
so brad will still play a major role uh
dana thanks so much
perfect person to be here for the
breaking news all right